GOT FROM KANYE WEST.
A LOT TO GET INTO.
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
WE START, HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES REVEALED
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD CONCERN
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN WATCHING.
THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION INTO
WHETHER OR NOT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA
WAS STARTED WITHOUT A SINGLE
SHRED, ZERO INTELLIGENCE.
I AM NOT MAKING THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION USES THE TOOLS OF
OUR INTELLIGENCE SERVICES THAT
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE USED ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WE HAVE LONG WANTED TO KNOW,
WHAT INTELLIGENCE DID YOU HAVE
THAT ACTUALLY LED TO THIS
INVESTIGATION?
WHAT WE FOUND NOW AFTER THE
INVESTIGATORS HAVE REVIEWED IT
IS THAT IN FACT THERE WAS NO
INTELLIGENCE.
>> Sean: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE FBI BEGAN A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION ABOUT AMERICAN
POLITICAL UNPROMPTED BY ANY
INTELLIGENCE AT ALL.
WHILE BACK.
LISTEN TO WHAT CHAIRMAN NUNES
WENT ON TO TELL MARIA BARTIROMO.
>> WE KNOW LONGTIME ASSOCIATES
OF HILLARY CLINTON, INCLUDING
SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL AND ANOTHER
PERSON, COREY SCHEER, WERE
ACTIVELY GIVING INFORMATION TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THAT WAS
SOMEHOW MAKING ITS WAY TO THE
FBI.
THIS IS FROM TWO PEOPLE WITHIN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WHO HAVE
PUBLICLY COME OUT AND SAID THIS
IN MAJOR NEWS PUBLICATIONS.
WE KNOW THERE WAS NO OFFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THAT WAS USED TO
START THIS INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THAT SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL
AND OTHERS WERE PUSHING
INFORMATION INTO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE TRYING TO PIECE IT
TOGETHER.
>> Sean: IT'S A DEADLY SERIOUS
CHARGE FROM THE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN.
IT WAS A FEW DAYS AGO THAT THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIRMAN MARK
MEADOWS, HE MADE A SIMILAR CLAIM
AND EVEN SUGGESTED THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION PLAYED A
KEY AND VITAL ROLE IN KICKING
OFF THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
>> WE SEE THE STATE DEPARTMENT
AND IT APPEARS THE WHITE HOUSE
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS INCLUDING
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF WERE
INVOLVED IN THIS WHOLE NARRATIVE
OF INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
THE MESSAGE, THE TEXT MESSAGES
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
REVIEWING AND THE OTHER
CORRELATING INFORMATION WOULD
STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT THERE WAS
NOT ONLY INFORMATION GIVEN TO
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT INDEED THEY
WERE INVOLVED IN DIRECTING SOME
OF THE ACTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND FBI.
IN THE FALL OF 2016.
THAT IS TROUBLING.
WHEN YOU SEE ONE PRESIDENT
ALLOWING THEIR DOJ TO GET
INVOLVED IN A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: DO YOU STILL THINK
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE WOULD
NEVER TAMPER WITH A POLITICALLY
CHARGED INVESTIGATION?
THINK AGAIN.
ACCORDING TO A COMPLETELY
UNDERREPORTED PART OF THE
RECENTLY RELEASED
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ABOUT
FIRING ANDREW MCCABE.
"McCABE SAID A HIGH-RANKING
OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT FBI AGENTS TAKING OVERT
STEPS IN THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN."
"McCABE TOLD US THE
CONVERSATION WAS VERY DRAMATIC
AND THAT HE NEVER HAD A SIMILAR
CONFRONTATION LIKE THAT CALL
WITH A HIGH-LEVEL DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL IN HIS ENTIRE FBI
CAREER."
THINK ABOUT THIS.
REMEMBER, THIS WAS ALL HAPPENING
WHILE ANDREW MCCABE'S BOSS JAMES
COMEY WAS GIVING HILLARY CLINTON
THE WHITE GLOVE TREATMENT DURING
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW SHE BROKE LAWS,
COMMITTED FELONIES AS IT RELATES
TO THE PRIVATE EMAIL SERVER.
THESE TWO FIRED CAREER
BUREAUCRATS ARE LIKELY HEADED
TOWARD A MAJOR COLLISION COURSE.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
ANDREW MCCABE IN DEEP LEGAL
TROUBLE OVER HIS LACK OF CANDOR,
LYING UNDER OATH.
WHILE SERVING AS THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR.
AND McCABE IS PROBABLY GOING
TO HAVE TO CUT SOME DEAL.
THIS MAY INVOLVE TURNING ON THE
OTHER GUY, JAMES COMEY.
McCABE SHOULD HAVE PLENTY TO
SAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, REMEMBER WHEN COMEY
AGREED TO CALL THE INVESTIGATION
A "MATTER."
AT THE REQUEST OF THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH.
JAMES COMEY LOOKED THE OTHER WAY
WHILE CLEANSING OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE BY DELETING 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS, ACID WASHING
WITH BLEACH, DESTROYING
CELL PHONES AND DEVICES WITH A
HAMMER.
TRY THAT AT HOME.
GOOD LUCK.
MAYBE MOST DAMAGING OF ALL, IT
WAS THE EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATORS.
CALL ME       COMEY AND HIS TEAM
CALL ME       COMEY AND HIS TEAC
CALL ME       COMEY AND HIS TEAE
CALL ME       COMEY AND HIS TEAR
CALL ME       COMEY AND HIS TEAD
CLINTON OF ALL CHARGES MONTHS
BEFORE THEY DID THE INTERVIEW
WITH HER IN 17 OTHER KEY
WITNESSES.
THE CRIME CLINTON MAY HAVE
COMMITTED AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH, OUR OWN
GREGG JARRETT AND OTHERS HAVE
IDENTIFIED THIS, 18 USC 793.
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, IT IS NOW THE SAME
CHARGE JAMES COMEY IS NOW
HIMSELF BEING INVESTIGATED OVER.
I HOPE HE'S HOPING HE HAS A
JAMES COMEY IN HIS LIFE AFTER HE
LEAKED THOSE MEMOS DEALING WITH
HIS MEETINGS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THOSE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
LEAKED.
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WAR AND
SOME OF THEM.
THIS WEEKEND THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED:
"JAMES COMEY'S MEMOS ARE
CLASSIFIED, I DID NOT DECLASSIFY
THEM.
THEY BELONG TO OUR GOVERNMENT!
THEREFORE, HE BROKE THE LAW!
ADDITIONALLY, HE TOTALLY MADE UP
MANY OF THE THINGS HE SAID I
SAID, AND HE IS ALREADY A PROVEN
LIAR AND LEAKER.
WHERE ARE MEMOS ON CLINTON,
LYNCH AND OTHERS?"
ACCORDING TO THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL, COMEY IS
BEING PROBED OVER WHETHER OR NOT
HE ACTED UNETHICALLY WHEN HE
LEAKED THOSE POTENTIALLY
CLASSIFIED MEMOS TO HIS FRIEND.
THE COLUMBIA PROFESSOR.
HIS NAME IS DANIEL RICHMAN.
WE KNOW THAT HE WENT ON TO LEAK
THESE MEMOS TO THE PRESS,
PUTTING THE WHEELS IN MOTION FOR
THE APPOINTMENT OF ROBERT
MUELLER AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THIS IS VERY INTERESTING.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, HE IS
SHINING A LIGHT ON THIS UNUSUAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DANIEL
RICHMAN AND THE FBI.
I HAD NOT NOTICED BEFORE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE INTERVIEWED
JAMES RYBICKI.
DURING THE DEPOSITION, IT WAS
BROUGHT OUT THAT DANIEL RICHMAN,
THE GUY WHO INFORMATION WAS
LEAKED THROUGH TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD THE
SPECIAL'S STATUS CALLED SPECIAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE STATUS WHERE
HE COULD COME AND GO IN THE FBI
WHICH MAY NOT MEAN MUCH BUT IT
SEEMS INTERESTING THE GUY THAT
COMEY LEAKS TO HIDE THIS SORT OF
UNFETTERED ACCESS INTO THE FBI.
>> Sean: AMAZING.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN DETAILED
POSSIBLE DEEP STATE COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE MEDIA AND SOME OF
THE HIGHEST RANKING OFFICIALS IN
THE GOVERNMENT OVER THE
SALACIOUS ANTI-TRUMP, UNTRUE,
UNVERIFIED CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR, PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JAMES CLAPPER PROBABLY LEAKED
>> THE PRESS WAS WORKING ON IT,
THE DOSSIER.
YOU HAVE THE COVER-UP, BRIEFED
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT.
>> IT GIVES IT WEIGHT AND THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED.
MY GUESS IS THAT CLAPPER IS ONE
WHO ORCHESTRATED.
HE SAID TO COMEY, YOU TALK ABOUT
IT.
AFTER THAT, CNN TALKS ABOUT IT,
PRINTED, AND THEN BUZZFEED
PRINTS THE WHOLE THING.
>> Sean: THIS SAME DOSSIER
USED TO ACQUIRE THE FISA WARRANT
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATES.
THEY LIED TO THE FISA JUDGES.
REMEMBER THEY NEVER DISCLOSED TO
PAID FOR THIS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS WAS CAMPAIGN OPPOSITION
RESEARCH BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
CLINTON, HER CAMPAIGN, FUNNELED
THROUGH THE LAW FIRM, PUT
TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN AGENT
BASED ON RUSSIAN AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND USED AS
EVIDENCE TO GET A WARRANT DURING
A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN AGAINST AN
OPPOSITION PARTY ALL THE WHILE
COMEY AND HIS COHORTS, THEY
NEVER DISCLOSED THE TRUE NATURE
OF THIS DOCUMENT, AND THEY LIED
TO THE FISA COURT JUDGE.
THAT IS A CRIME WHICH BRINGS US
TO OUR NEXT TOP STORY.
THE DEMOCRATS LAUGHABLE LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
WIKILEAKS, AND RUSSIA.
WE KNOW THIS COURT FILED
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
IT'S NOTHING.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND.
IT'S A DESPERATE PUBLICITY
STUNT.
BREAKING TONIGHT, THEN DNC'S
BRAND-NEW LAWSUIT REVEALING WHAT
IS ALMOST AN UNBELIEVABLE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE ANTI-TRUMP
DOSSIER.
THEY PRESENTED IT TO THE FISA
COURT TO GET THE WARRANT.
NEARLY EVERY NIGHT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT IT.
THE DOSSIER THAT WAS USED TO GET
THE WARRANT THAT SUPPOSEDLY
LINKS TRUMP TO RUSSIA IN THE
MOST SALACIOUS, EMBARRASSING
WAYS, THAT WAS NEVER VERIFIED.
IN THIS LAWSUIT, IT IS NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND.
IT'S NOT EVEN IN THERE.
LET'S LIVE TO THE JUDGE BUT NOT
THE NEXT CHARGE.
OKAY, I REALLY UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS ALONG WITH A
CLINTON CAMPAIGN WERE THE ONES
THAT PAID A FOREIGN SPY TO PIECE
TOGETHER THIS DOCUMENT ON
RUSSIAN LIES AND RUMORS AND
SO-CALLED RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
LISTEN TO WHAT CHAIRMAN NUNES
HAD TO SAY ABOUT THIS TOTALLY
EMBARRASSING POLITICAL
HAIL MARY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE KNOW WHO COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIANS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT
THEY COLLUDED WITH RUSSIANS BUT
THEY HIRED FUSION GPS.
THEY HIRED A LAW FIRM THAT HIRED
FUSION GPS THAT HIRED A BRITISH
SPY THAT COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
DIDN'T JUST OPEN UP A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THEMSELVES.
THEY SHOULD NAME THEMSELVES AND
SUE THEMSELVES SO THEY CAN GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT DO THEY
HAVE ON THEIR SERVERS.
WHY DIDN'T THEY GIVE THOSE
SERVERS TO THE FBI?
THIS IS NOTHING MORE, NOTHING
LESS THAN A CONTINUATION OF
FUND-RAISING OFF THIS SCANDAL.
>> Sean: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
CLEARLY AS MANY ARE NOTING, THIS
MOVE FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS NOTHING BUT DESPERATION.
EVEN SOME OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY INCLUDING CLAIRE
McCASKILL, THEY ARE ADMITTING
THIS LAWSUIT IS MERELY A
DISTRACTION.
BY THE WAY, SHE IS UP FOR
REELECTION.
IT'S PROBABLY JUST FOR RADICAL
EXPEDIENCY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED HIS
RESPONSE ON TWITTER.
"JUST HEARD THE CAMPAIGN
WAS SUED BY THE OBSTRUCTIONIST
DEMOCRATS.
THIS CAN BE GOOD NEWS IN THAT WE
WILL NOW COUNTER FOR THE DNC
SERVER THAT THEY REFUSED TO GIVE
TO THE FBI, THE DEBBIE WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ SERVERS AND DOCUMENTS
HELD BY THE PAKISTANI MYSTERY
MAN AND CLINTON EMAILS."
BY THE WAY, WE WILL BRING YOU
MORE INFORMATION OF THAT PLAYS
OUT.
FINALLY WE WILL END ON SOME GOOD
NEWS YOU WILL NEVER HEAR FROM
ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA DESPITE
WHAT I DESCRIBE AS THE FORCES
WORKING TO DEFEAT THIS
PRESIDENT, ONE TO PREVENT THEM
FROM GETTING ELECTED, THEN
DELEGITIMIZE HIM AND GET HIM
THROWN OUT OF THE OFFICE.
YOU HAVE THE MEDIA, YOU HAVE THE
NEVER TRUMP-ERS.
THE DEEP STATE.
NOW THE TRUMP AGENDA KEEPS
SEEING MASSIVE, MAJOR PROGRESS
BOTH HERE AND ABROAD.
THIS INCLUDES BIG PROGRESS ON
THE ECONOMY.
LOOK AT THIS.
14 STATES, 14, HAVE NOW HIT
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS,
INCLUDING ALABAMA, ARKANSAS,
TEXAS, EVEN CALIFORNIA,
WISCONSIN.
THE U.S. IS ALSO SAYING RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND HISPANIC
AMERICANS.
ON THE INTERNATIONAL FRONT, WE
WILL TALK MORE ABOUT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS LATER.
LATE LAST WEEK, NORTH KOREA
ANNOUNCING.
THIS IS HUGE.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
THEY WILL SUSPEND ALL BALLISTIC
MISSILE TESTINGS THEY PLAN TO
CLOSE A NUCLEAR TESTING SITE.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS TONIGHT,
KIM JONG UN ALSO HAS DROPPED HIS
DEMAND THAT ALL U.S. TROOPS
LEAVE THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
THEY CAN STAY IN SOUTH KOREA.
THIS COMES AHEAD OF THE
PRESIDENT'S UPCOMING MEETING
WITH THE NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR.
THESE MAJOR GROUNDBREAKING
DEVELOPMENTS CAME AS A SHOCK TO
MANY OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
ONE, FAKE NEW CNN REPORTER
LITERALLY BECAME SPEECHLESS.
THIS IS PRICELESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> KIM JONG UN SAYING
NORTH KOREA NO LONGER DOES ANY
NUCLEAR TESTING.
MIDRANGE AND INTERCONTINENTAL
BALLISTIC MISSILE TESTING.
HE IS SAYING THAT THE NUCLEAR
TEST SITE IN THE NORTHERN AREA
NEAR THE CHINESE BORDER HAS
COMPLETED ITS MISSION.
THEREFORE IT WILL LIKELY BE
CLOSE.
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT.
FRANKLY, A HUGE WIN FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I AM REALLY ALMOST SPEECHLESS
HERE AT THE PACE AT WHICH
NORTH KOREA HAS DONE THIS YOU
TURN.
IT ALL STARTED WITH DONALD TRUMP
AGREEING TO SIT DOWN WITH A
SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN.
HE IS DOING GOOD NEWS FOR THE
WORLD.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TONIGHT IS
THE LATEST AND ONE IS A LONG
LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THERE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
BUT YOU WILL LIKELY NEVER SEE
THESE THINGS REPORTED IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
NOW I HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
AND THIS MESSAGE OF THESE FIVE
FORCES WORKING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, THESE NARRATIVES, ARE
NOW DYING, ESPECIALLY
TRUMP-RUSSIAN COLLUSION AND THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA IS WORKING
WHICH IS GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HERE IS MY FINAL WORD.
IT IS TIME TO PUT THIS HATRED,
THIS OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE HATRED
IN THE MEDIA, IN THE DEEP STATE,
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ASIDE.
WORK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, A
MORE PEACEFUL, PROSPEROUS
AMERICA.
MAYBE WE'LL ACTUALLY GET ALONG.
COMING UP, WAIT UNTIL YOU MEET
OUR GUEST CANDACE OWENS.
YOU ARE ABOUT TO SUPPORT -- HEAR
ABOUT THE SUPPORT SHE IS
RECEIVING FROM KANYE WEST.
ITS DRIVING LIBERALS NUTS.
YOU WILL HEAR A VICIOUSNESS
AGAINST THIS YOUNG WOMAN THAT